the planet has been taken father the
third I came pledges eternal loyalty to
your cause
except in my terms
well done daughter well done
why
by the look of it you seem content
enough at the time
[Music]
refuse
after my planet died I had nothing no
one when I thought I never would I was
alright with that I had a new vocation
and I found mute and at my side you
became the fiercest woman in the galaxy
that's why I chose you to find the soul
stone I'm sorry I disappointed you I am
just not because you didn't find
because you did
and you lied I gave you my trust paid it
with deceit at least be honest about it
now I could make you tell me you see me
I know that I never wanted to force you
into anything
that's why when you left me all those
years ago I allowed it you allowed it
you haven't been under the impression
you escaped
daughter I raised you you didn't raise
me you kidnapped me orphaned me and
imprisoned me everything I hate about
myself comes from you I stayed because
you taught me I didn't deserve
I found people that Sean hated you had a
family here that one we just didn't care
what happened to it
you
[Music]
let's go let's put on our mean faces
hold on there's a flying there is
something awesome about seeing these
heroes interacting with each other for
the first time
I'm doctors the doctor I can't walk
it's gonna look awesome cool so cool all
right kid
you're an adventure novel studio
adventures infinity war on digital today
you